[Music]
in ursula kayla green's fourth earth sea
novel tahanu one of the key themes that
runs throughout the entire work is the
interconnection between the relations
between men and women within their
society and in their relationships
and power power understood
both in terms of you know the very broad
sense of power being able to make people
do things to compel to arrange things
according to one's wishes
and in terms of magic since this is
earthsy and magic plays an incredibly
important role within
the you could say economy
and
social structure and the plot of all the
things that are going on
in earthsea
and this this theme is explored
in large part through the things that
10r the main character
says to other people has people say to
her or in her interior reflections as in
for example the case of handy one of the
abusers of her adopted child theroux
where she reflects on how you know handy
is doing this thing and doesn't he
realize this so there's a lot of
discourse about power and i want to
begin
sort of towards the end when she and ged
are talking about these matters together
a passage that we'll come back to
and she
says
[Music]
you seemed in your power
as free as man can be but at what cost
what made you free
and i
i was made molded like clay by the will
of the women serving the old powers or
serving the men who made all services in
ways and places i no longer know which
then i went free
with you for a moment and with ojin but
it was not my freedom only it gave me
choice and i chose i chose to mold
myself like clay to the use of a farm
and a farmer and our children i made
myself a vessel i know it's shape
but not the clay life danced me i know
the dances i don't know
who the dancer is and so this is a very
important teaching here there's always a
contingency
in the freedom and the power
that we we have
but we also do have some measure
of choice and responsibility and neither
of them
are entire they come together
now
tenner is an unusual person she's not an
ordinary woman and so if we begin with
one of her her first
ruminations about this tenner was
somebody who had power she was
as she says set apart and power was
shared or given with her
she says when tenner had first lived in
reality 25 years ago moaz had not been
an old witch but a young one she ducked
and bowed and grinned at the young lady
the white lady ogian's warden student
never speaking to her but with the
utmost respect tenor had felt that
respect to be false a mask for envy and
dislike and distrust they were all too
familiar to her
from women over whom she had been placed
in a position of superiority so when she
has power
herself whether in this novel or back in
the tombs of atuan
these women see
themselves as common and her as uncommon
as privileged priestess of the tombs of
atuan or foreign ward of the mage of god
she was set apart set above power is
about these vertical relations
then she says men had given her power
men had shared their power with her
women looked at her from outside
sometimes rivalrous often with a trace
of ridicule she had felt herself the one
left outside shut out she'd fled
from the powers of the desert tombs then
she'd left the powers of learning and
skill offered her by her guardian ogian
she turned her back on that so for a
while she enjoys power
but in a certain respect it's not really
her power it's a borrowed power and what
does power do does it get her what she
actually wants know it it sets her apart
and sets her at odds with others so she
she leaves behind
that power and there's a couple
different descriptions of that in
passages running throughout this this
text
several different reminiscences of it
but here's one of the key things
she turned her back on it gone to the
other side the other room where the
women lived to be one of them a wife a
farmer's wife a mother a householder
undertaking
here again the key term the power that a
woman was born to
the authority allotted her by the
arrangements of mankind the arrangements
of mankind social arrangements the ways
in which we often take
the the
culture the customs as being
natural
later on for example her son spark
returned from uh his ship after the crew
has been broken up refuses to
put his dishes even into a tub or the
sink that's women's work right these are
social arrangements and tenner goes into
that
at the same time she still remains
rather unusual and not just because of
her her white skin
but because she in effect
becomes a dragon lord
so
when she en engages
um
with you know
the the dragon collecting um she thinks
to herself well
i'm you know
i'm not supposed to have
this kind of power but i'm also
somebody that a dragon came to and
talked with
so are there women dragon lords does
this open up a door a possibility and we
see throughout the novel
if there's anybody who is unusual except
for of course thero
because of her her trauma and injury and
then what happens with her at the end it
is tenor right she does come from this
this background
she asks god later on about the
possibility of women mages and even a
woman archmage as we're going to come to
later so we've got tenar as a character
who has experienced power who is on the
high side of things at least to a
certain extent there's still power
exercised over her who is on the low
side of things you know for example when
the two wizards at ogen's death
basically ignore her even though she is
the one who was his ward and knows the
dispositions the one wizard is is very
resentful of her he's very misogynistic
um aspen the wizard of ray alby
we also encounter moss
moss is a village witch
and moss is some is a woman of power in
fact she recognizes that ged no longer
has his power because of the power that
she has which she likens to being like a
seeing person who can tell whether other
people have eyes or are blind or have
only one eye or three eyes
and moss is going to give
tenar
metaphors of the
power that men and women have
both in in life and in relation to their
magic and she's putting forth a kind of
essentialism women are one kind of thing
men are another kind of thing it's
interesting she's very fascinated by the
gelded men the eunuchs of the of atawan
when
tenor tells her about that she won't let
that conversation go because they're
kind of in between right
here's the things that moss will say
a man's in his skin see like a nut in
its shell it's hard and strong that
shell and it's all full of him full of
grand man meat man's self and that's all
that's all there is it's all him and
nothing
inside and then tenor says what if that
man's a wizard
well then it's all his power inside his
powers himself see that's how it is with
him and that's all when his power goes
he's gone empty nothing
and then she says what about a woman and
here is where we have one of the most
famous speeches from this novel oh a
woman's a different thing entirely who
knows where a woman begins and ends
listen mistress i have roots i have
roots deeper than this island deeper
than the sea older than the raising of
the lands i go back into the dark i go
back into the dark before the moon i was
no one knows no one knows no one can say
what i am
what a woman is
a woman of power a woman's power deeper
than the roots of trees deeper than the
roots of islands
older than the making older than the
moon
so this is one way of looking at things
men instead of men are from mars
from venus basically men are an identity
they are what they are and are contained
within themselves women are what they
are but their roots go down into the
depths moss doesn't say whether this is
all women or whether it's just women of
power but that is the metaphor
that she's going to
use
she also um is going to
to say another thing
about this that
um men are
especially wizards are like great pine
trees right
they stand up but
they can be
they can be destroyed
easily by the wind whereas of course
women are much more like
brambles blackberries again the metaphor
of roots their roots are
in some respects if not deeper at least
appropriate to them when a great win
comes they won't be tumbled down
and so that's that's a key thing and
their magic works like that as well
women's magic
you know in the the world that they live
in there is the high magic and that's
only for
men you know they go to rock and they
study there
everybody has been told that there have
never been any women mages or anything
like that part of the backstory that
turns out to be false as we find out in
the fifth
and sixth books
but
this is the sort of reigning ideology
that you know witches are undisciplined
men their magic can actually be
disciplined
there's also an
interesting uh interconnection between
men their magic and celibacy that moss
is going to bring up as well
and this is precisely
because she's talking about gad and she
says that ged is is essentially
like a 15 year old
boy
why because
he entered into his magehood around that
time and had to give something up and
here moss says something really
interesting
they witch themselves some will tell you
they make a tradeoff like a marriage
turned backward with vows and all a
marriage turned backward isn't that an
interesting way to think of it
so they get their power but that to me
has got a wrong sound to it like a
dealing with the old powers more than
what a true witch deals with and the old
mage that that's ogen he told me they
did no such things but i've known some
women witches do it and come to know
great harm by it and tenor says the ones
who brought me up did that promising
virginity
and then
moss goes on and says
that's the power of this you don't think
you can't nor do they once they've set
their spell how could they given their
power it wouldn't do
you don't get without you give as much
that's true for all surely so they know
that the witch men the men of power they
know that better than any
but then you know it's an uneasy thing
for a man not to be a man no matter if
he can call the sun down from the sky so
they put it right out of mind with their
spells of binding and truly so
because you know
otherwise they would they would be using
their spells to
satisfy their their bodies lust and
tenner says they set themselves apart
and she says i a wizard has to do that
and then she said
but you don't
me i'm only an old witch woman dearie
and she says
when you had a man moss did you have to
have to give up your power and the witch
says not a bit of it
so
she says but you said you don't get
unless you give is it different then
for man and for women
what isn't deary i don't know and now
here's where tenor says something really
interesting
it seems to me we make up most of the
differences and then complain about them
i don't see why the art magic why power
should be different for a man watch
which and a woman witch unless the power
itself is different
or the art so this is a very important
sort of figuring of things why is magic
if a person has power why does it vary
according to to gender
is it that the art is only
learnable by men
is it that
the
power itself is different in men and
women
and
moss says something and she's very
confident about this
tenera doesn't quite buy it a man gives
out dearie a woman takes in
and here's where they turn to talking
about reputation a reputation as being a
kind of power
so
tenner says
ours is only a little uh yeah
here's where moss is ours is only a
little power next to theirs but it goes
down deep it's all roots uh that was the
thing about the blackberry bramble and
then she she says it's probably good
that ged left because people in the town
might begin to talk and tenor says what
do you mean to talk and she says well
you're a respectable woman dearie and
reputation is a woman's wealth and now
tenner says
her wealth her wealth her treasure her
horde her value like the dragons who
found caves who build fortresses for
their treasure for their horde to be
safe to sleep on their treasure to be
their treasure take in take in and never
give out going back to this a woman
takes in a man gives out
and then moss says well you'll know the
value of a good reputation when you've
lost it tis isn't everything but it's
hard to fill the place of
and then you know tenor turns it on and
he says well would you give up your
power to be reputable and moss says
well i wouldn't
because the power is really all i know
but you you 10 are you need to think
about that so
notice that
moss is not given you know the sole uh
place of interpretation of this this
problematic
when we come to ged we note that his
power has been poured out as he tells us
like a cup he had to use his power to
close the breach between the living and
the dead the dry land and the world of
earth sea
and in doing so he poured out everything
that he had and now he is humiliated he
feels shame he feels fear
because people want him to be who and
what he was the archmage he flees from
the king's men the king who he
saved the world with he doesn't want to
see him
later on ged will come back and there's
a very interesting discussion that's
taking place between him and tenor she
says
how did you know
to
follow these guys who he ends up you
know stabbing one of them with a
pitchfork saving tenar and thero from uh
theroux's former abusers how did you
know to
to find them
and he's you know he's
he's kind of uh you know
meditated on this and
she says it's the kind of thing that
happens to a wizard and he says and
others
maybe my dear you're not trying to
reinstate me
no no no not at all if you were a wizard
would you be here
and then she says but what i want to
know is this
is there something besides what you call
power
that comes before it maybe
or some something that power is just one
way of using
like this ojin said of you once that
before you'd had any learning or
training as a wizard at all you were a
mage mage born he said so i imagine that
to have power one must first have room
for the power and emptiness to fill and
the greater the emptiness the more power
can fill it but if the power was never
got or was taken away or was given away
still that would be there
he says the emptiness
emptiness is one word for it maybe not
the right word and then ged says
potentiality
what is able to be to become
and then tenor says
i think you were on that road just there
just then because of that because of it
is what happens to you you didn't make
it happen you didn't cause it it wasn't
because of your power
it happened to you because of your
emptiness
after a while he said that isn't far
from what i was taught as a boy on rock
that true majory lies in doing only what
you must do but this would go further
not to do but to be
done to
all right so get is is now reversing a
polarity you can say here and then she
says i don't think that's quite it it's
more like what true doing rises from
didn't you come and save my life didn't
you run a fork into hake that was doing
all right doing what you must do and
then get says is this a wisdom taught
you when you were a priestess of the
tombs and she says no no that i didn't
get it from there arja was taught that
to be powerful she must sacrifice
sacrifice herself and others a bargain
give and get
and i cannot say that's untrue but my
soul can't live in that narrow place
there is a freedom beyond that beyond
payment retribution redemption beyond
all the bargains and balances there is
freedom and so there's this very
complicated thing that's going on in
this discussion right there
are arha at one time tennar is telling
about what power was like when she was a
priestess and why she had to leave that
behind get is coming to
gropingly realize that he isn't totally
without anything but what he has is an
emptiness or potentiality that is still
aligning him with things
we're going to come back to that in a
moment let's talk about handy and other
evil people and the power
that they have
handy is one of the people who has
horribly abused the child pharaoh who
had been
starved beaten raped cast into a fire
and he tries to get hold of her once
again
and the king
essentially stands in the way
now
there's an interesting reflection we see
that that thero has closed in on herself
again and a lot of the progress that has
been made towards like opening up to the
world seems to have been lost
tenor says it's so easy for handy to
take the sunlight from her
to take the ship and the king and her
childhood from her and it's so hard to
give it back a year i've spent trying to
give them back to her and with one touch
he takes them and throws them away
what good does it do him what's his
prize what's his power is power that
and emptiness notice that emptiness here
is being talked about in a different way
a
a void
a
vanity right the power that so many of
us exercise over each other through
attempting to exploit to dominate
to humiliate to
do things to another so that we can feel
alive or we can feel one step up even
though we may be getting crapped on from
everybody uh on on high on downward
power coming from
the exercise of resentment it's it is
real power in that it has effects it's
not power that can accomplish anything
for
good
finally we talk about uh what a woman's
power could be once again with ged
and ten arm and there's an important
discussion that's taking place
where she asks him why couldn't a woman
be
a mage or even an ark mage
why not
ged says a woman on gant can't become
archmage no woman can be archmage she
doesn't make what she became and
becoming it the mages of roke are men
their power is the power of men their
knowledge is the knowledge of men both
manhood and magery are built on one rock
power belongs to men
so you know god here is enunciating sort
of what has become the traditional way
of looking at things then he says
something really interesting
if women had power
what would men be but women who can't
bear children
and what would women be but men who can
this would efface
the gender difference if they both had
the same capacity for power if we had an
inequality right and ged seems to be
suggesting that this would be a bad
thing
tanner then says
haven't there been queens weren't they
women of power and god says the queen's
only a she king
and then he says i mean men give her
power they let her use their power but
it isn't hers is it
it isn't because she's a woman that
she's powerful but despite it
she nodded and then says okay fine
what's a woman's power
and god says i i don't think we know
when a woman when has a woman power
because she's a woman with her children
i suppose for a while in her her house
maybe
um and and
you know so this is like the traditional
view as well
domestic duties the woman is totally in
charge of the household except of course
when she isn't
and uh tenner isn't satisfied with that
either and she goes on and she says why
are men afraid of women
and ged says
now showing a bit of insight if your
strength is only the other's weakness
you live in fear
and she says yes but women seem to fear
their own strength to be afraid of
themselves so we have this complex
dynamic there
men
most men are afraid of women
and because of that they want to exert
power over them to control them to make
them stay in their place good example of
this is when tenna reflects on how her
husband wouldn't answer questions with a
real answer
trying to use her ignorance as a way to
have power over her at the same time
it's not simply that men have dominated
women women fear their own
power and here we get this very
interesting discussion
of trust
ged says are they ever taught to trust
themselves and tenor says trust is not
what we're taught if power were trust i
like that word if it weren't all these
arrangements one above the other kings
and masters and mages and owners it all
seems so unnecessary real power real
freedom
would lie in trust not force
as children trust their parents he said
so this sounds like
a breakthrough what real power would be
is real freedom would be trust like the
trust that children have with their
parents when we're not talking of course
about an abusive relationship
and then gen points out that even this
this ideal is not perfect
as things are he says even trust
corrupts the men on rock trust
themselves and one another their power
is pure nothing taints its purity so
they take that purity for wisdom they
cannot imagine doing wrong this is a
very important passage she looked up at
him he had never spoken about rogue thus
before from wholly outside of it free of
it
and then
she says maybe they need some women
there to point that possibility out to
them
and she goes on and says
i don't see why if there can't be she
kings there can't be she
arc mages and ged argues with her and
[Music]
she says all right we don't even know
what a woman's power is all right but
all the same why can't they find an arc
mage
so
she's suggesting something that is
actually going to be worked out
as part of the back history of earthsea
and something going forward as well
in the subsequent volume so lots of very
interesting structure here in the way
power is understood and how it is
involved in the relations between men
and women in earthsea
you